I learned a lot of things from movies I
learned how to make a speech from the
movie code bodyguard Whitney Houston
when she sings the Suns I look at her
wow that's the way that you make a
speaker because I never know how to make
speech because I'm not actor but when I
saw the movie I say wow
if you sing from your heart if you've
seen naturally if you are yourself so I
realized and I learned a lot from the
movies you know even learn from the
Godfather's I learned my favorite movies
the forest the gum you know these are
the things that learned so much then I
would discuss about the muse the
inspiration so we got from movies what
kinds of business ideas have you said no
to I'm saying no to a lot of ideas
because as a CEO I have to say no to
opportunities because if I say yes I
probably get a five thousand
opportunities every day but where the
years are know everything based on the
meshing that way helpings doing business
easier if it's on that will consider if
somebody come in saying we will make a
lot of money I'm not interested you just
watched two amazing clips from Jack Ma
take the next three minutes and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you